all right chantelle and pedro
congratulations on season two of the
family chantelle
what are you excited for fans to see
what has you most excited
ah fools you're going to find a lot of
things this season right now it's a lot
of
special team that you're going to find
in dc so
i'm most excited for everyone to meet my
brother
they haven't met before there are four
of us and nobody really knew
sometimes they'd see pictures of the
entire family i wonder like who's this
extra person there but
now we can finally introduce my brother
royal my brother royal has moved back to
atlanta
with his new wife from the philippines
we met
online uh she she sent the message to
you yeah she she met me first
let's talk about that because i saw in
the comments a lot on youtube
everybody is confused about royal where
did he come from
what went behind the decision for him to
be a part of the show how did that
happen
well basically he decided that
he wanted to be on it i mean royal
wasn't
included in the previous season because
he wasn't living in georgia but now
since he's moved back
he decided that he wanted to participate
we're happy to have him on the show
because
i want everybody to know that i have an
older brother everybody thinks that i'm
the oldest but i do actually have an
older brother
and you two have a few similarities one
that you
you've both chosen to marry someone who
lives outside or who is from outside of
your country
royal is married to angenette who's from
the philippines
when you first heard the news that they
got together and they were solidifying
their marriage
did any red flags go off in your head
immediately or did it take
time well i was initially excited
that um he was getting married to
someone from a different country because
you know i really enjoy different
cultures
but there have been some conflicts that
we
that we will face and um that you will
see
on the family chantelle season two so
look out for those
well and jeanette does she seem like
your brother's type when you saw her did
you say oh
that's you know who he usually goes for
was that a surprise for you
my brother he always usually
dates somebody outside of his race and
normally it may be like you know an
asian
person or either hispanic person so it
wasn't
surprising to me that he would be
interested in a filipino
well you mentioned in the teaser that
you don't think royal trust her
what made you have that impression and
do you trust her
you're going to find on the show about
that because that's very
interesting well i'm getting the vibe
that it's no
yeah because that's very interesting we
can't give too much away you're going to
have to just
wait until the show airs on october 12th
and find out all of the secrets
yes i believe that you're going to like
it a lot
okay well chantelle a lot of people say
that or a lot of the fans
think that your family should start a
private investigation service
because you all tend to go on these
investigation
missions so my question for you is
if your brother is a grown man and he
seems
pretty happy why did you all feel the
need to dig into his relationship
without giving too much away
what made you say okay no something's
fishy here i believe
just only for patricia maybe they try to
you know
how you are you might try to put
everybody
well we love my brother royal the entire
family my mom's very protective
and you know it may have seemed
like we we had to dig but we didn't
really dig too far
scratch the surface and you'll find out
but you're just gonna have to watch
okay well pedro it seems like at the
beginning
they were pretty welcoming of and
jeanette how did you feel
seeing that knowing what you had to go
through
look i've been fighting for almost
four or five years try to get at the
family you know try to be inside the
family
and see and janette coming for the big
door
like opening door was a little bit
interesting to me because
i coming for the bad door like i need to
i i coming
for the scratch you know what i mean it
was so different
that she's so different me than then
there i believe there was like
they have double double standards on
time
well i can like okay because
okay okay because she got me she coming
from the philippines okay coming to my
republic
why why the team that she was like
okay we're going to do the big welcome
for her
we know we know what we're not going to
ask him too many questions about
relationships things like that
for pedro you're going to get the
question you know what i mean okay but
you can say that but
i think that my family has you know been
around that ring with you several
times and maybe they've learned their
lesson and maybe they're trying to
change and
have a open mind this time i mean you
can't make the same mistake twice
three times no but i believe if if
you do it's like it's like
how to say that were you feeling a bit
of jealousy pedro
was i did the jealousy um
uh she i can't say i didn't feel it'll
be you know disappointed
okay i don't can say i can see no yellow
i feel a little disappointed because
the way that i go to the family the way
they treat my family too like that
where they treat me they treat my family
know what's the good way because they
believe
that that my family have like ruined
a merry ring business all the time and
try to pull me like how did your family
treat me and my family
because you from your family started
from the beginning okay
no okay okay
and jeanette so we're talking about
antoinette and roy
wouldn't it be lovely if my family
learned their lesson from dealing with
you and your family
and are taking royals relationship with
anjanette
and being open having an open mind
and i think that's really what they're
trying to do baby but question
chantelle i have a question just to
piggyback off of what you just said
we see when you all go to the
philippines it looks very
similar to what happened when your
family went to the dominican republic to
see pedro's family
so do you think pedro and chantel do you
chantelle do you really think your
family has learned that lesson and pedro
what do you say to fans who say okay
they're treating and jeanette's family
the same way they treated yours
i said we are equal like i said now we
are equal like
at first you weren't but now you are
yeah it's okay yeah it doesn't matter
now
now the truth is coming on maybe it was
a sneak in the past
maybe this had to be sneaky like okay
less a friend we got a good person
and the last moment well i don't think
that my family is really you know
trying to treat angeannette or her
family bad
but you're just gonna have to watch and
see
for yourself so looking back you think
what we're gonna see was justified
like how your family approached a
situation it was justified
[Music]
well i really just don't want to give
too much away that's my problem here
you're asking some really really
nitty-gritty questions
that's what you're doing and that's what
you're supposed to do we want to know
i get that i totally get that pedro you
you somewhat grilled royal just a bit
when you were asking him about his
relationship with angenette in the
kitchen
that was in the teaser so based off of
that looking back now do you think that
that was fair
considering what you had to deal with
with chantelle's family
i do that because you know where i do
that because
fightful no no no i do that because
nobody was
asking about his relationship
how about how janet coming from where
about
how they meet each other you know
because that's so interesting to me
because
that that was your revenge no no it's
not it's not where's my image
it doesn't wear my rebellion just all i
can say is like
it's nobody asking questions here i want
to know
because i asked river i asked him thomas
do you know about the relationship they
say no no we don't know don't say i said
you don't want to know they say no
we're not but my family is going into
this really delicately
and trying to not stir the pot too much
too soon with uh royal and angenette you
know because they've seen what happened
last time
with you like okay i feel like they're
just trying to keep an open mind about
um and uh open mind about her and and
her culture
and try to get to know her yeah
but without coming off too harsh yeah
usually
was like simple with simple questions
that says no was nothing terrible
it's only a question for c where no they
call me that's it
well the last time we spoke to you two
at the beginning of quarantine
you said that there's no babies coming
anytime
soon but quarantine has changed a lot of
people's minds about things
is that still the case no babies on the
right like to have a baby
i say something we practice every day
we've been practicing
we only practice every day for getting
ready bro we don't have we want to have
babies
i believe right now that we have
we have our goal you know and the
you know i know the babies are blessing
but they want to be is blessing are they
good in the right side right now
chantal she needs to work in the school
you know and you know the number one
thing is
um i do feel i do feel of the burden of
needing to
make a healthy relationship with your
family before
i actually get pregnant that's important
to me
and the the beatings lie you know we
living like
bots we live in la little we still have
we little apartment we know
we we not get the chance to move yeah
because you know
quarantine war you know chantal need to
finish the school you know i need to
finish my school i need i need to go
i need to go to the school you know what
i mean like i need to have my degree i
need to do something for my life i'm not
[ __ ]
tired still working out in a warehouse
yeah
yeah you got to get a baby and then you
know it's like it's like a team play you
know
it's a lot of a
and the case but
yeah i do want but i wanted the right
time because
i wanted everything be perfect you know
the people say it's not it's not the
perfect mom it's never going to be the
perfect moment
for her baby but my case i
will like that the moment may be it'd be
perfect like
how i'd be apartment you know how old
that baby need you know
and i wanna i one girl my baby you know
like like the way that my father never
grow me
you know you know what i mean i know
when i made the same mistake
that my father did to me like leaving me
by myself you know because
he know where's estable and his mind you
know what i mean i'm gonna be
stable everything's good family
everything perfect
in that case i wanna we wanna bring the
baby like maybe
with them babies